c'est la une du quotidien français
Libération quelques heures après la fin
de la COP 27 l'urgence attendra peut-on
lire tandis qu'en arrière-plan la terre
en feu un portrait certes pessimiste
mais qui témoigne de bilan peut
réjouissant le Canada n'a pas été un
leader à la hauteur de ce qu'il aurait
pu faire Patrick bonnet le visage de
Greenpeace il voit une occasion manquer
de la part du gouvernement Trudeau c'est
définitivement honteux de voir que le
Canada a fait autant de place à
l'industrie pétrolière et gazières
au-delà des belles paroles il n'a pas
livré concrètement d'engagement
supplémentaire à réduire ses émissions
plus rapidement il déplore que le Canada
est selon lui davantage écouter les
lobbies pétroliers et gaziers tandis que
des entreprises pétrolières canadiennes
étaient présentes au Pavillon du pays on
voit que le gouvernement canadien
accepte quand même de donner une tribune
à cette industrie-là et pour nous c'est
d'une incohérence totale l'organisme
équitaire dénonce un double discours il
ne peut s'empêcher de rappeler au
passage que Justin Trudeau brillait par
son absence lors de ce grand rendez-vous
se sente garant d'une responsabilité
vis-à-vis des autres pays si la
principale figure politique n'est pas
présente le Canada peut-il encore jouer
un rôle de leader sur la scène
internationale malheureusement non je
pense que le Canada s'est brûlé
quand tout comme 27 et qu'au même moment
tu donnes des permis d'exploration
pétrolière dans des zones matines
protégées à des industries ça l'envoie
un message contradictoire
le fond d'aide pour les pays vulnérables
suscite assurément un brin d'espoir
c'est malheureusement une COP qui nous
amène des deux mises avancées mais qui
ne suffira pas pour que le Canada
obtienne la note de passage selon
Patrick bonnet ici
Radio-Canada Montréal